tonight FN C's hosted a town hall with
Bernie Sanders I wasn't invited so I
guess I'm out of town but if I had an
hour with our leading preeminent
socialist here's what I'd ask him number
one if you had to teach a course on
Marxism or Leninism how would you
address the 100 million plus dead that
they left behind what caused it beyond
administrative error number two
socialists bring up small successes in
Europe without mentioning that economic
growth is miserable compared with the
United States why hide that number three
you live in the greatest economic system
in history yet you see in socialism a
system rejected by nearly every nation
that has tried it as somehow better
given the previous questions I just
asked why four do you see equality of
opportunity and equality of outcome as
the same thing should there have been a
cap on the book royalties which made you
a millionaire should you only have one
home instead of three also can you give
me an example of economic inequality
that exists after you factor in age
experience in education older people
tend to have higher incomes and more
wealth you are older and richer than
most aren't you proof of economic
mobility not inequality 5 since you
became a millionaire you've trained your
sights on billionaires there are 585 of
them in the United States if we took all
their money what our problems be solved
it's been said that if you aren't a
liberal when you're young you have no
heart but if you aren't a conservative
when you're old you have no brain what's
your Excuse joining us now or Bret Baier
and Martha McCallum how they're
muttering to moderating tonight's Town
Hall with Bernie Sanders I think it went
pretty soft on Bernie what do you think
well listen Greg we'd really like to
have you here because obviously one
through five sounds good you're going to
hear tonight yeah something like that
yeah all right let's go around the horn
you guys want to talk to the players
about the location because I think it's
super interesting that this where you
are that there was a 13-point swing
these were Obama voters in 2012 but by
13 points Trump voters in 2016
and just curious if I'm sure you're
going to ask him if Bernie Sanders
thinks this districts like those states
like those that he thinks he can flip
back I think it's one of the reasons
he's doing this
I mean Pennsylvania is one of the
swingingest states of swing states at
this particular region even more so as
you point to the points there are many
Trump voters who switched over
they were Democratic voters for a long
time and they went to Trump in 2016 and
I think that that's one of the reasons
he's here it's also very interesting if
you look at the voters who were Bernie
supporters in the primary process 11 or
12 percent of them ended up voting not
for Hillary Clinton but for Donald Trump
now President Trump so these are the
areas that he needs to come to I think
it's very politically astute of him to
know that this is where he needs to be
if he wants to start to flip those
voters in places like Pennsylvania
regret as you know senator Sanders ran
on trade in 2016 and he is called the
president's trade policy's weak on labor
protections will you ask him tonight why
the president's trade policies are
weaker than the policies that he is
pushing inside the Democratic primary
trade is definitely a topic that will
come up Donna it is key to this region
we are in the shadow of Bethlehem Steel
a plant that closed down in 1995 this
area was devastated when it did it's a
key issue for voters here and throughout
really this entire region you look at
those states Michigan Pennsylvania
Wisconsin Ohio I think that's really the
battleground for 2020 as you look at the
map now a lot of those people are the
category that were looked upon as The
Forgotten voters and both Bernie Sanders
and President Trump tried to tap into
that and what we've heard from Bernie
Sanders in recent weeks is that he
believes that the president has failed
those forgotten voters now do the voters
feel that way that's gonna be the big
question as we move forward you know if
you're staying at the Bethlehem Hotel
there's a picture of me in the bar I
can't tell you why it's there but I
think you should stop by and just you
know have a drink Jesse
figure them yeah I'm sure they're gonna
do that great I just have a lot of
respect for Bernie Sanders I think the
fact that he's doing this Fox News
townhall this early in the race and
while he's atop many of the polls shows
a lot of political intelligence because
he's signaling to his competitors in the
Democratic primary that I'm not here to
hit softballs and he's also showing that
he's got a general election mindset he's
going to look for as many voters
wherever they are into a widest audience
as possible you're not going to listen
to any of my questions because you've
probably all got them nailed down by are
you gonna have a moment question you
know like the boxers or briefs question
or something like that like ask him
about Tiger Woods or Game of Thrones or
something like that not Bernie
maybe that was more apt for Bill but is
there going to be a moment question
where it goes you know everybody wants
to know about a pop-culture scenario
well I think if we shared it with you
now that it might ruin the moment true I
don't think that it's likely to do that
exactly there's a new poll that's out
that says bernie is now taking the lead
well you guys press them on that is
there a growing support for him and why
yeah I think that you know almost every
poll has him in the lead as a declared
candidate we you know know that Vice
President Biden is not yet in here and
he leads many polls but you're right he
is he went from think of the evolution
here from the outsider who was pressing
Hillary Clinton and came very close to
now the front-runner who has the most
money in the Democratic field is getting
the biggest crowds and now in some polls
is leading and is leading as the
declared candidate and I don't think
that the Alexandria Acacio Cortes is of
the world right now would exist or be as
accepted as they are if it weren't for
the ground that Bernie Sanders laid down
so it's his story it really is
extraordinary because he's forced a
conversation in America
that I never thought I would live to see
whether or not we should be a capitalist
or a socialist nation and that's a
question that is you know very
fundamental to where we are in this race
right now which you know is an
interesting place to be in this country
we should also point out that we're
probably minutes away from getting
Bernie Sanders tax returns for ten years
so I don't know why they put it out
thirty minutes before the townhall but
we'll have it all right well Bret and
Martha have fun thank you for joining us
we'll see you tonight at 6:30 p.m.
Eastern for the Bernie Sanders town